Peggy 12
okay so after the release of X rebirth
we are listening to feedback and try to
add those features first that are
requested by most people and which are
possible to add fast so in today's video
I try to explain some of the things
added between page 122 and 125 which
comes out this week one request we heard
a lot was that people miss the proper
logbook to keep track of their progress
so we have added a logbook to the info
menu here from the main menu as you can
see the lock book has taps with
categories each event locked goes into
one category and you can filter the
logbook to only show staff from one
category or delete all entries from one
category you are not so interested in
now we think some of the most important
events are already logged but it would
be great if you could send us your
suggestions for more things that you
want to see in the logo to get an even
better overview of your ships it is now
also possible to rename your ships from
the info menu when you select the name
line you can click on the rename button
and type a ship name
now a quick run through the changes
around trading let's start with a little
thing one feature that was asked a lot
was an easier way to see all trade
office of a station so you now have this
new offer button below the station info
menu which brings you to a filtered view
of the trade menu that only shows the
office of this particular station this
next thing is not new but i think it was
overlooked a lot a very good investment
for traders is definitely the trade
computer software extension available
from all mechanics once you have this
installed instead of collecting each
trade offer you will immediately have
all current rate of us of a station
added to your trade computer memory for
as long as the offers are valid so this
can save you a lot of exploration time
flying around stations if you want to
focus just on trading the reason I
showed the trade computer extension is
that there isn't closely related new
feature in patch 125 which we called
agents we have redesigned the small talk
inside stations a little bit people were
complaining that this part of the
gameplay was too repetitive so what we
changed it said once you played this
small talk minigame successfully instead
of getting a random reward you can now
ask for the reward you want this is
especially useful if you want to find
certain NPCs or need a very specific
discount unaware you are no longer
forced to play the game many times but
get the reward you want directly and one
new reward in this game is now the trade
agent I mentioned before you hire people
aboard the station and they will always
keep your trade computer up to date with
information from that station so this
also includes new offers and not just
those that were available when you were
near the station yourself all stations
where you did this will then have an eye
icon in the map
so these were two ways to collect trait
of us more quickly and with this it
should not require a lot of time to have
quite a good overview of what wears are
available around you or even across a
larger area the last feature i'm going
to show in this video is a new method of
locking targets many of you stated that
you wanted the x3 style explicit target
locking with the keyboard back so you
will now have 'rememorable buttons that
work a lot like the old T and E buttons
and all the x-games by default this is
now mapped to shift f4 or neutral ships
and shift efore enemy ships only the
shift F button will first choose the
ship which is closest to your crosshair
while shift e selects the enemy which is
nearest to your ship so maybe including
one that is just behind you I think it
is especially this ability to lock on
enemy ships quickly even if you don't
have them on screen that people wanted
mostly together with these two new
buttons also comes the ability to switch
through all ships of the same type with
page up and page down there is a lot
more we are working on and I'm going to
post the list of some of our current
work on the forms today
your computer ready to receive new
command